FELIPE HOFFA: It's 4:00
PM in New York City,
and it's impossible
to get a cab.
Can we use data to fix this?
I'm Felipe Hoffa, a developer
advocate for Google.
I am here to attend a
hackathon hosted by NYU
and the Rubin Center For
Transportation, and the TLC--
Taxi & Limosine
Commission of New York--
where top data scientist
and researchers will
use data to solve this problem.
How?
Well, we've got data.
We got all the taxi trips.
Chris Whong, how do you
manage to get this data?
CHRIS WHONG: The Taxi
& Limosine Commission
has an internal
data analysis team.
And they released a tweet with
a visual of available taxis
by time of day.
And my response, as an
open data advocate, was,
is the raw data available
so that everyone
can do this kind of analysis?
And the response on
Twitter was, it's not
available for
download, but it is
available from a Freedom
of Information Law request.
I sent in the form.
And within a couple
hours, I got a response.
So a couple days later, I
had 175 million taxi trips
in CSV format on a hard drive.
FELIPE HOFFA: 175
million taxi trips.
And then you managed to share
this data with the world?
CHRIS WHONG: People
started coming to me,
to meetups that I went to
to actually get the data.
And there were so many
people messaging me
that, finally, I was like,
it's time to put this online.
And within 24 hours, it was
all over Google BigQuery.
There was a really
awesome reddit thread
of people doing simple
analysis from BigQuery,
and just slicing it
up, and figuring out
what's in the data.
FELIPE HOFFA: So all the New
York City taxi trip for 2013,
and now shared with BigQuery,
and anyone can easily
analyze them.
So stay with me to see
what happens tomorrow,
what solutions we find.
And remember, at the end of
the day, someone will be fired.
Wrong show, sorry.
Traffic!
We are here at NYU Rudin
Center for Transportation.
And today's a historical day.
It's the first time the
TLC Taxi & Limousine
Commission for New York
City is meeting and working
with citizens to take
a look at the data
that the TLC is
sharing with us today.
We'll try to come
up with solutions,
answers, discoveries,
and I can't
wait to see what happens today.
RODNEY STILES: Today, we
shared all of 2014's trip
data with the additional
information added.
And the way that we
did it is we loaded it
onto Google Cloud
Storage and loaded it
into BigQuery, which is how
all the participants accessed
the information today.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello.
I'm here with Ben Wellington,
a visiting professor at Pratt
and also the data scientist
behind iPod New York.
So when you were
looking at the--
BEN WELLINGTON: It's a
parking ticket data set up.
And I wanted to find out how
much revenue in parking tickets
every fire hydrant in
New York City was making.
So first, I mapped out the
top 250 grossing fire hydrants
in New York City, in
terms of ticket revenue.
And these were the two, by
the way, top grossing hydrants
in the entire city.
And if you look at the amount
of revenue they were generating,
they were generating
over $55,000 a year
among the two hydrants
in parking ticket
revenue for the last,
at least, five years.
It turns out that it looked like
a bike lane between the hydrant
and the parking spot.
So the car would pull in
and say to themself, well,
I'm not next to the hydrant.
There's a bike lane
between me and the hydrant.
A month later, they actually
repainted the parking spots
by adding these stripes here,
so they prevent future people
from making this mistake.
So this is a time
when open data has
changed the infrastructure of
New York City in a small way.
But imagine this
happening locally
in everyone's neighborhood.
If every person got
together and found
some of the issues in
their own neighborhoods,
put their minds
together, we can all
start to make
changes very locally.
JO RAUSEN: I think that
collaboration with citizens
is really important,
because again,
we come from the policy
from what we know,
working with a lot of
industry stakeholders
that are very, very vocal.
So it's really great,
when we finally
get citizen voices in here.
These are things that
actually matter to me,
and that are important
to me, and can
help us understand better
what their problems are,
and just be a part
of that dialogue.
JEFF FERZOCO: I am
excited to be here today
to help the TLC
better understand
exactly what is happening for
taxis between 4:00 and 6:00 PM.
Ultimately, what
we're going to do
is take the data from
BigQuery, put it into redash,
download it, bring
it into [INAUDIBLE]
and make a map of where
people get picked up.
See where the cabs are
spending the most time,
and look at them specifically
between 4:00 and 6:00 PM,
because between
4:00 and 6:00 PM,
cabs shift over from
one driver to another.
And if a driver doesn't
have to do that shift,
it can take advantage of the
extra amount of people that
need service during rush hour.
Data that is open means that
it's accessible by anyone.
And having it be open means
that people can look at it.
They can come up
with their own ideas.
They can start making decisions
that make cities better
places to live.
And having open data be
open, and free, and available
makes that all
happen a lot faster.
SARAH KAUFMAN: I think
the best part of today
was that we've been focusing
so much on the data leading up
to this event.
We've been looking
at the data nonstop.
And today, we've had five
taxi drivers here talking
about the issues that
they deal with every day.
You can look at
data all day long,
but you may not be able to
see it from the other side.
ALLAN J. FROMBERG: It
wasn't just numbers.
It wasn't just mathematics
in ones and zeroes.
There was very much a
human factor present here.
And the fact that we were
taking that approach to data,
adding the human factor
in with the data,
and putting it all in a
bowl, and it was better
than the sum of its parts.
MALE SPEAKER: Right
now, the agency
is really taking a
hard look at our rules,
and figuring out what
makes sense today
and what doesn't with all
this emerging technology.
And this is one
piece in the puzzle.
This is another part
of that feedback loop
to take this information and
create a progressive policy,
and so I think this
will definitely
be a part that process.
BEN WELLINGTON: Our
agencies do great work,
but they have limited resources.
So when they embrace
the open data movement,
it allows citizens
to give back and find
some of the maybe
issues or problems,
and suggestions of how we
can run our cities better.
SARAH KAUFMAN: With
hackathons next year,
I hope that we'll see these
kind of micro improvements using
civic hacking to resolve issues.
We have a lot of
smart New Yorkers,
a lot of people who can look
at data, look at numbers,
and understand where the issues
are and suggest policy changes
that we might not
have seen otherwise.
We had access to more than
160 million taxi trips taken
during 2014, and a glimpse into
the for the for-hire vehicles'
data, like Uber and
Lyft, confirming
that there are 20% less
taxi drivers on the road
when we most need them.
We spent the day going
deeper into the data.
Noel Hidalgo and
David Marulli looked
for patterns that may reveal
the best shift change locations.
Arlene Ducao and Chris
Willard explored the potential
of having three shifts instead
of the traditional two.
Jeff Ferzoco, Ben Wellington,
and [? Carson Kim ?] took
Uber's data to compare
their diver's behavior with
traditional taxis'.
And Damon Wischik
went deeper into why
we have the current
shifts, and also,
surfaced interesting
behaviors about tipping.
Why would people tip more
after a New York Knicks loss?
There's a lot more to discover,
and it's your turn to dig in.
Thank you for joining us.
This was an amazing day to see
how citizens, taxi drivers,
academia, government can come up
together and look for solutions
using data, using open data, got
and the right tools to do it.
That's it for today.
Make sure to follow us for
the next Big Data Story.
I'm Felipe Hoffa.
Goodbye.